私は最強の母親子。今日は息子の屋姉ちゃんに中華を食べさせてあげました。
やちゃん、さっきの茶飯美味しかったわねえ。おお。
あ、ラブも置いてきちゃった。戻らなきゃ。
ダめです。お母さん。
私の息子が中にいるの。中に行かせて。強すぎてまだ中に入れません。でしょ。
タプタプ
プ。あ、
あんた邪魔よ。あ、
ラブラブス完了。
ありがとう。
ありがとう。しょ、し長、
君の優れた身能力、救急意識全てが素晴らしい。
君を消防士に任命する。へ
ええ。
今日からよろしくな。彼が上官のハワ君だ。お前の面倒を見るハワイだ。硬いだ。娘とそのが取り残されている。行くぞ。ラジフラ見られて。あらえだ。
天長か待て。
おお。や行くわよ。
まずは状況確認だ。
まずは1回に水を発射。それから2
回に救助に渡れ。
はい。
おお。くそ。胃を触らない。ぶち出てくれよ。私が持つわ。
新人は黙ってみて。
ボスの重さは70km。
俺がやった方が早い。
命が危ないのよ。私が行った方が早いわ。
おお。
邪魔よ。
救助。ええ。貸してなさい。おあ。
一見な之助。
え、
いこと愛の素晴らしいにより君を消防視長に昇格させる。愛。お金だち。救助したらお金がもらえるのね。
最近救急の仕事全然ないわね。平和が
1番だろう。
あ、そうだ。家事がなかったらあほ。お母さん、そのお金どうしたの?これはね、たくさんの人を助けたからもらったのよ。
すごい。じゃあ見に来る。
行きたい。
お金の稼
イエーイ。
おなら下
通報して急助。
助けた。助けた。
よかった。
到着しました。ちょっと遅いんじゃない?もう助けちゃったわよ。
[音楽]
あ、いいのがいたいた。
イね
え。
もしもし。ナ事故です。え。
到着しました。
おそ、私1人で十分だったわよ。
最近の活躍はすごいね。ボーナスだ。
マニー。
しかし最近火災事件が多いな。家事の原因は何だったんだ?
あ、それ多分こいつらで捕まえてきました。
違う、
違うか。聞けせよ。今の言葉しただけやね。
よくやった。どう見てもこいつらがほカだろう。ボーナスだ。ありがとうございます。
え、無理、無理。
ちょっとお母さん。お母さんやってることやばいよ。
は、
あんた口ご応する気?これで頭冷やしなさい。
ああ、今日朝マックの特徴でラブもらえるのにあと
5分しかないわ。行かなきゃ。
絶対許さねえ。一刻は大変なのよ。今すぐ起きなさい。バック到着。そうだ。帰り道に増やしておこうと。
さ、夜ご飯巻くよ。やねちゃん。やねちゃん。もしもし。ちゃんどこいんの?
お母さん助けて。家事に巻き込まれて
は?今すぐ行くわ。
はい。家事ですか?今すぐ行きます。
はい。
うちの息子は家事でみんな助けて。それが他にも火事件があり、人でも消防者も足りてなくて。
そうだ。帰り道に火増やしておこうと。
でもみんな来てよ。私の息子なの。
お前1
人で足りるっていつも言ってただろう。
人で行ってこい。命ちで優先順位なのない。
そそうよ。私1
人で行けるわよ。ちゃん待っててね。う、酸素が薄くて
分も持たないわ。あと水がどこにもない。自分で探すしかないわね。お母様屋。
やめっちゃあ。
酸素が足りなくてもう進めない。私ってバカね。
お金に目がくらんで大切なこと忘れてたみたい。ごめんね、やっちゃん。お母さん。お母さん。
イエーイ。
やしくアメリ作戦成功だ。イエー。
よし、行くぞ。
実は遡ること3時間。あ、
絶対許さねえ。
君のお母さんについて聞かせてくれ。実はな
んだって?今までの崩壊水事故は全てお敬語のせいだった。金に目がくらんだお金の討伐作戦開始だ。
ラジ
えイガ倒したぜ。
え、
ボーナス最高。
え、まさか怒りで生き返った。
お前らしろ。
うわ。
おほ。
ああ、気持ちいい。食
らんねえ。あ、
ああ、すら飛んでた。ああ。
ちゃん痛かったね。寒い。今日
3時間しか寝てない。
この先に命の水があるらしいね。
熱い熱い熱い。[笑い]
何をしてんの?
皆さんこんなに頑張ったんで
2026年1月10
日ノマン彼のライブイベントあるので皆さん是非来てください。こちらからアルコのこちらからみんな来てね。頑張ったから。
[笑い]
熱い。本当に安すぎるよ。ちゃちゃちゃチャンネル登録、チャンネル登録チャンネル登録よろしく。チャンネル登録。チャンネル登録。チャンネル登録よろしく。最初はグチャンネル登録。チャンネル登録まね。
[音楽]
チャンネル登録